[music]
Hi, I'm Christopher Crockett,
and I'm the astronomy writer at Science News.
In 2017, we'll be learning about new things in our own
solar system to the center of the galaxy
out to galaxies billions of light-years away.
One of the things I'm looking forward to in 2017 is
astronomers figuring out where fast radio bursts
are coming from.
These are these really big blasts of radio waves
that appear to be coming from other galaxies,
but we have no idea what's causing them.
Astronomers are getting really close to
narrowing down where these things are coming from
by detecting them at one telescope
and then quickly catching them with another telescope.
And I've heard some rumors that there might be some
really cool discoveries and announcements
coming up pretty soon.
A bit closer to home, there's a project
called the Even Horizon Telescope
that's been running for about a decade.
What they're doing is linking together radio telescopes
around the world to create one giant virtual telescope
that's about the size of the Earth,
and what they're hoping to do is
actually see the supermassive black hole
that's about 28,000 light-years away
in the center of the galaxy.
And we've never been able to actually see a black hole
before because, well, because they're black.
They don't give off any light,
but what they're looking for is actually
light that's being bent around it by its immense gravity.
It's a phenomenally difficult thing to do.
It's like trying to see an orange
on the surface of the moon.
The Juno mission is at Jupiter,
and it's been there since July.
But now it's going to really start doing
its regular science, mapping the interior of Jupiter,
getting a 3-D picture of what the biggest planet
in our solar system is like on the inside --
looking for how much water there is,
whether or not there's a core.
That will tell us a lot about how Jupiter formed,
and that can tell us a lot about
how the rest of the solar system formed
and solar systems throughout the galaxy.
But I think one of the coolest things
going on in the solar system this year
is the end of the Cassini mission at Saturn.
After almost 20 years in space
and over a decade at Saturn,
the mission is coming to an end.
The spacecraft is going to start going
where it's never gone before.
It's going to start repeatedly diving
between the rings and the planet.
As they fly through the rings,
they're gonna spin the spacecraft,
so that the big radio dish is facing forward
They're using that as like a deflector shield,
and so if anything from the rings hits it,
it'll just bounce off the antenna
and protect the instruments behind it.
So that'll allow them to get really close to Saturn,
see details they've never seen before.
They'll actually be able to figure out
just how massive the rings are
which might tell them where they came from.
And then in September, the mission is going to end
by deflecting and diving into the atmosphere,
and spacecraft will plunge to its death,
making measurements all the way down.
The reason they're ending it that way
is actually to protect the icy moons around Saturn --
moons that we think have
saltwater oceans beneath them.
Cassini may still carry some sort of
biological contamination on it,
and they don't want to remotely risk
our biology getting into the oceans of Saturn's moons.
So they're just going to toss the
spacecraft away into the planet.
It's always a really cool year
to be writing about astronomy.
We're always discovering new things,
and I'm sure 2017 will be no different.
[music]